hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to in two
minutes this week set in a galaxy far
far away well not really star wars
battlefront is out this week and while
our reviewer Mike mahadi praised the
game for its authenticity to the source
material he ultimately gave it 7 fuse
out of 10 due to its oh so repetitive
combat so maybe it's not the best movie
video game of all time naturally that
award goes to Snoopy's grand adventure
but you've got to admit things aren't as
bad as they used to be when pretty much
every major release was accompanied by a
less than stellar video game here's some
of my personal favorites the first rule
of Fight Club should have been you do
not talk about the truly awful tie in
Fight Club beat-'em-up while it features
a number of characters and locations
from the movie I think that's supposed
to be Brad Pitt sadly it was an
ultimately boring and repetitive
fighting game with strangely
proportioned characters and a bizarre
lack of sound design on the plus side
though fred durst is an unlockable
character which i suppose was good for
2004 next up the game the four hour for
show host dave Jewett called completely
unfinished abysmal and a disgusting cash
in on a franchise that didn't even
deserve a game that's right 2003
Charlie's Angels despite featuring the
movies famous cast including Cameron
Diaz Lucy Liu and Drew Barrymore the
game was universally panned upon release
for its poor gameplay including unique
fighting styles for each angel that all
looked remarkably exactly the same it
was wife with bugs repetitive mission
structure a poor camera and random AI
that were dressed in such a way that
they can't actually made no sense to the
level that they were in let's just take
a special moment to celebrate superhero
movie games because they are pretty much
in a justice league of their own like
Superman on the n64 that game was bad
for a number of reasons mostly due to
its trouble development because of
meddling license holders DC and Warner
Brothers in the end the game suffered
from unresponsive flying controls bugs a
terrible frame rate and a draw distance
that was so poor they had to write a
narrative reason to explain why the
virtual metropolis was so foggy and it
wasn't any better for Marvel despite
outliers like spider-man
to and seriously remember how good
spider-man 2 was before the days of the
shelf straining disney infinity
publishers mmm sega quickly shove out
game tions to phase 1 Marvel movies
who's pretty much only redeeming
qualities was that they secured the
original actors to reprise their roles
although they quite frequently sounded
like they really didn't want to be there
doesn't matter they'll suffer to this
all the same and let's finish with
perhaps the most infamous 1982's ET the
extra-terrestrial pushed out of the door
in just five weeks to hit that lucrative
Christmas release window ET fell so far
short of its sales predictions that
millions of cartridges were buried in a
landfill in New Mexico not only that but
the gameplay was so bad because eating
love to fall down random holes at every
opportunity their players literally
would send ET home back to Atari so are
there any that i missed any gems in the
rough spider-man 2 can't be the only
truly decent movie tie-in let me know in
the comments section below and a bit of
news Wednesday is basically gonna be
luci day here on gamespot so one week
you'll get in two minutes and the next
week you'll get that other show what I
do reality check thanks for watching
don't forget you can find me on Twitter
at Lucy James games and I'll see you
next time